bioshock infinite is a pretty good game
there's a lot that it does well but
there's also a lot that it does wrong
it's got a fantastic story with a
wonderful dynamic between its two main
characters but it also has a severe lack
of interesting world building and an
awful dlc that was ultimately
unnecessary welcome back to another
story review the series where i not only
give you a retelling of a game's story
but also my thoughts along the way so
without further ado
let's get started so firstly since this
is the final game in the series i do
have a question for you all would you
prefer that i take each of these videos
on the games and combine them into one
full length project it would be the same
videos as before but i understand lots
of you prefer to watch these while doing
other tasks so now you can just go to
that video instead of flipping through
the channel to find all three parts plus
i'll most likely add some other sections
to that video that i didn't include in
the other parts like the two novels that
we haven't discussed yet so let me know
what you think so where else would we
start then at the intro this is the most
important part of a game's story but
this is taken to the extreme with
bioshock because these intros are made
to intrigue the player enough to keep
going you may find this confusing as i
literally just described an intro was
meant to do but think back on the
previous games for a moment bioshock 1's
story was a bit confusing as all of a
sudden we arrive at rapture and are
helping the first guy we meet without
even a chance to question why we're
doing this in the first place bioshock 1
obviously clears this up at the end of
the game and one of the best ways i've
ever seen but i can almost guarantee
that the setting and combat of bioshock
1 carried you throughout the game rather
than the story of just killing the big
bad guy well bioshock infinite does the
same thing its story is hidden and never
mentioned until the very end because the
devs know this they need to intrigue the
player enough in other ways to keep them
going like the aforementioned setting
and gameplay this is why it builds off
the original game's unique introduction
bioshock evidence starts in 1912 with
the player on a boat being taken to a
lighthouse for context since this game
is in 1912 that means we are 48 years
before bioshock 1 even occurs that means
all the previous games and their events
had never happened yet rapture wasn't
built hell i don't even think ryan was
born yet we also get to see our
characters face hear their voice and
know their name all within about two
minutes which is a lot faster than the
previous games our protagonist name is
booker dewitt who was brought here to do
a job booker is then given a box with a
few items such as a pistol a code a
picture of our target among other items
the picture of the girl has a note on
the back that says bring the girl to new
york unharmed so we can assume that
we're here to find this person on the
card the people taking us to the
location are unknown as they're only
referred to as man and lady however the
way they talk is odd almost as if
they're watching us from a distance they
don't talk to booker and if he doesn't
climb the ladder they'll say this
he's not moving he will
eventually i suppose he does
it's like they think they're invisible
or analyzing some experiment like some
scientists would do it just feels off as
we approach the lighthouse we get more
information on the task at hand as the
note reads bring us the girl and wipe
away the debt once again we can assume
that booker has some debts that need to
be paid and it's because of these
threats that he took this job in the
first place everything initially looks
pretty normal until we see someone dead
and tied up with a sign that reads don't
disappoint us it continues to get even
weirder as when we finally get to the
top of the lighthouse we input the code
and the sky turns red momentarily as a
horn blares every time the color changes
a chair appears and seeing as we're at
the top without anywhere else to go we
take a seat
no no god damn it
dude
assumption in the count of five
count to four no no three
two
ten thousand feet
hallelujah
words cannot describe the beauty of
colombia it's truly a magnificent place
but after we arrive we see a lot of
religious symbolism and are told that to
enter colombia we have to be reborn anew
via baptism we accept and are able to
explore colombia to our hearts content
but we have to remember that we're in
uncharted territory and have to blend in
except that may not be as easy as it
sounds as we discover that the false
shepherd is prophesied to enter colombia
with a defining mark of an a.d on their
hand the same one that booker has we
enter the city's raffle win and are
given the reward of pelting a couple
with a baseball until our identity is
revealed and are forced to fight i know
i sped through that so allow me to
explain why bioshock infident on its own
has a pretty fantastic intro arguably
the best in the series but it reaches
unprecedented levels of quality when you
take into account bioshock 1. colombia
and even bioshock infinite are the
antithesis of rapture and bioshock 1.
not just in the setting of the two games
but the values of each setting and the
actual sequence of events that occur in
the game's intros it's clear from the
first moment of the game that the
developers took heavy inspiration from
the original the reason being that
irrational games the devs behind
bioshock 1 also made infinite whereas 2k
games irrational games's publisher made
bioshock 2. that's not only why bioshock
2 feels so different from the other
games but why these two feel so similar
bioshock 1 starts on a plane that
crashes in the ocean we then take it to
a lighthouse which then leads to rapture
we start in the sky and end in the sea
with the lighthouse being the mediator
between these two parts of the world
whereas bioshock infinite starts in the
sea and ends in the sky with the
lighthouse being the mediator again one
game's start is the other game's end our
first encounter with rapture is quite
dark as the first person we see gets his
guts spilled on the floor by a splicer
from the moment we enter rapture we are
thrown into the deep end however as you
play you start to appreciate rapture
more and it's almost like a home away
from home minus the splicers of course
raptor is a really relaxing place and
the thought of what this looked like in
its prime gives you that sort of warm
and welcoming feeling whereas colombia
does not our first interaction with
colombia is the opposite of dark we're
welcomed by many religious people before
walking the streets of the city where
the citizens of colombia will be having
wonderful conversations about the city
and will even greet and compliment
booker you get that warm feeling that
rapture provides later in the game at
the very start but that warm feeling
goes away eventually as you uncover
colombia's true backstory furthermore
each city's ideologies couldn't be
farther from one another rapture's
tagline is no gods or kings only men on
top of this religion while accepted is
not publicly shown as andrew ryan didn't
want any public institutions related to
religion within rapture this is why we
see the bible amongst the cargo and
smugglers hideout in colombia religion
is the basis for its creation where the
people of the city worship father
comstock who is the leader of the
founders a group and religion based on
many traditional religious and patriotic
values we're also immediately greeted by
religious quotes and bible verses while
descending into colombia upon stepping
out we see a stained glass painting
depicting father comstock bringing the
people to colombia and there's also tons
of other statues showing the city and
father comstock's glory i'm not a
religious person so i can't say with
complete certainty but i'm convinced
that majority of these depictions of
father comstock are literally ripped
from famous artwork related to jesus and
the bible because while i can't put my
finger on what exactly it's referencing
these paintings feel oddly familiar to
me as if i'd seen them before in a
different context we are then shown this
massive room filled with candles and
water that is used for prayer and
baptisms once we awaken colombia we can
see the statues of the founding fathers
who are also revered as religious or at
least prominent figures within colombia
so we have a king in the form of father
comstock who worships a higher being
quite different than what andrew ryan
believed in ryan believed in objectivism
a belief based on the individual and due
to rapture's location and values it
allowed those involved to succeed on an
individual level this even extends to
the gameplay as while some splicers work
together not everyone is aligned with
one another everyone seems to be acting
out of pure self-interest in colombia
its citizens work together for the
benefit of the city and the father
they're acting as a group rather than
individuals sort of like the family from
bioshock too but by far its most
staggering difference is in its
inclusivity ryan and rapture didn't
really care about the inner workings of
a person as long as that person had the
drive to seek something greater in their
life in rapture there is a prominent
picture called the rapture's best and
brightest and within this picture are
both men and women those women also
being tenenbaum and sophia lamb arguably
the two most important women in rapture
there's also dr su chong who is of asian
ethnicity and while not in the picture
there's also charles milton porter owner
of the thinker and he's african-american
rapture is also very accepting in
regards to sexual orientation as sandra
cohen one of rapture's best and
brightest is gay given the time frame of
the game it's possible people have their
own opinions on someone's sex and race
but at the very least they're welcomed
into rapture and not rejected for their
differences this is in stark contrast to
colombia where most of its regular
residents are white in fact the first
black person we see is tied to a post
because this couple is in an interracial
relationship since colombia is ruled by
one man and not ruled by the city's
basis of creation that person's
ideologies are the golden rule of the
city and father comstock is a white
supremacist who is extremely racist
against anyone who isn't white and
refuses to condemn organizations that
believe in this ideology a good example
is the order of the ravens in colombia
who believe in racial purity this is
reinforced by the fact that they are not
only dressed as kkk members but have
paintings and statues that depict
abraham lincoln as the devil and john
wilkes booth his assassin as a hero
within the organization we can also see
a chinese prisoner being tortured and
killed via ravens and to top it all off
we see a statue outside of the building
of comstock defeating a multi-headed
serpent however this serpent has the
heads of three men who are black chinese
and jewish all with exaggerated features
like big noses and lips as for things
such as gender or sexual orientation
it's not outright said but there is
definitely some hints that colombia's
values fit with ones from the current
time period there's a severe lack of
lgbt representation in this game with
the only ones i could find being the
rare case a guy hits on booker
furthermore women at least those within
authority or power seem to be tolerated
rather than celebrated there's a
kinetoscope of rosalind lutes who is a
quantum physicist and the sole reason
colombia can even float to begin with
but in this film at the end there's a
question that says how does that darn
thing fly to which she responds it's
quantum mechanics but at the bottom it
reads we say it's more like women's
intuition however there is clearly women
in power like daisy fitzroy so while
this doesn't outright prove that all
women aren't viewed the same as men at
the very least it shows how much people
downplayed lutes creation of colombia
and her intelligence and seeing if she's
easily one of the most important women
and the most intelligent person in
colombia i can't imagine how a regular
woman would be seen within the eyes of
men besides all the symbolism and
ideologies regarding colombia the actual
interactions within the intro are
extremely fun before taking part in the
raffle we can explore the carnival area
where we can take part in carnival games
involving weapons and vigors which acts
as a sort of hidden tutorial we also see
these weird interactions most notably
the statue of rosalind lutes changing to
who we'll discover is robert lutes this
telegram being given to booker that says
not to pick number 77 which happens to
be the ball we choose at the raffle and
then the final one where the loot testes
make us play heads and tails and not
only does heads win every time but it's
won a lot all of them are nice touches
and subtle hints regarding the game's
actual plot bioshock 1 and infinite are
the complete opposite of one another and
it's by far the best dichotomy i've seen
in the game to date bioshock 2 build off
the world of the first game but decided
to change the ideology of rapture to
show how the other end of the spectrum
could operate in the same city but
infinin took this idea and ran with it
by not only creating a city completely
opposite to rapture in just about every
way but also took specific moments and
cutscenes from the first game and made
those opposite when compared together
it's genius game design genius
storytelling and overall gives bioshock
infinite the best intro in the series
getting back on track we just turned to
guard's brains to mush and are now
fighting the colombian police while
trying to find the girl we came here for
within this section is the
aforementioned order of ravens but there
also seems to be a secret home a little
farther down for people who actually
praise abraham lincoln there isn't much
here but it is nice to see that some of
the residents don't all share the same
values after multiple battles with the
city's police were briefly stopped by
comstock himself who claims to not only
know who booker is but all of his past
sins including wounded knee the
pinkertons his gambling and alcohol
addiction and someone named anna this
made the situation a bit more tense is
now we aren't operating away from the
watchful eye of comstock as he not only
knows who booker is but why he is here
it makes the player question who this
comstock really is and how he's related
to booker furthermore it also forces the
player to question what booker did we
then make it to monument island the
place where this girl should be located
and it's clear here that the game is
trying to set up the typical girl
trapped in the tower trope but the way
this was presented in the game is really
well done as once again these chilling
feelings of the story continue to grow
all throughout the area are caution
signs and a plethora of equipment and
wires that make it feel like a
laboratory rather than a home it's a lot
different than what one would expect as
you would think this girl is either
relaxing in some random house or at a
very top of a luxurious tower and while
the latter is technically true large
rich towers don't usually come equipped
with caution signs and chalkboards full
of data it continues to get even weirder
as we see photography rooms filled with
pictures of her and rooms that seem to
be made for testing an experiment most
likely involving her there's even a
projector that has some film of this
girl doing specific tasks like dancing
painting and lock picking we then get to
see how the operation was created as
there is two-way mirrors in these rooms
allowing them to spy on her without her
knowing we also get to see her open a
portal to another world before closing
it momentarily it's given just the right
amount of time to confuse the player on
what the hell just happened without it
being overly long and also calls back to
the rest of the tower now it makes sense
why they were testing and observing her
she clearly has these superpowers booker
tries to find his way around the rooms
but falls through the ceiling which
rightfully startles her this girl is
elizabeth and she is one of the most
intricate characters in the entire
series she is shocked by booker's
arrival in the tower and attacks him
until she realizes this is the moment
she's been waiting for she can now
finally escape this tower that she has
been stuck in since she was a child so
elizabeth and booker escape the tower
together until elizabeth's mechanical
bodyguard songbird shows up and attempts
to stop booker the bird almost succeeds
but booker despite falling an incredibly
far distance is able to live thanks to
falling into one of columbia's beaches
so what's really going on here well
elizabeth has the unique ability to open
tears these tears are essentially
ripples in time that allow the person
viewing the terror to see into an
alternate dimension this is why we can
hear the song fortunate sun through one
of the tears later in the game despite
that song not being created for another
40 years these tears aren't unique to
the individual as we see more
kinetoscopes of people talking about the
tares so everyone can view them but not
everyone can create them the two most
notable characters that can create these
terrors is elizabeth and lutes rosalind
before colombia was experimenting with
atoms and found a way to indefinitely
suspend atoms in mid-air this led to the
aptly named blue test field discovery
comstock would eventually meet with
lutes through some way and through their
collaboration would create colombia
using her lutes field as thanks for
helping create the floating city
comstock promised that she could
continue her experimentation and it was
during these experiments that she met
robert despite what the game will
initially tell you robert is not the
twin of rosalind he is rosalind in an
alternate world rosalind was born a man
named robert these two are the same
person just in different timelines as
for elizabeth she was able to create
terrors from a very early age it's not
explained why just yet but it will be
towards the end of the game whereas
lutes is able to create one through
science and experimentation elizabeth
can just create one when she wants she
also mentions that when she was younger
she was able to create new worlds with
these tears but now she isn't able to as
often this is most likely due to the
siphon equipment in the tower as it's
literally siphoning her powers away i
don't think it's necessarily removing it
altogether but more like storing it as
when we get to the end of the game she
is way more powerful implying that we
were able to give them back to her
speaking of elizabeth after we regain
our footing on the beach we go to find
her and try to get her out of the city
but it seems that comstock and his
forces have already caught on to our
location this is also elizabeth's first
time experiencing combat and i really
like how they didn't just have her deal
with it as right at the moment the
shooting starts she runs away and we
have to chase her down the reason she
ran is because elizabeth thinks booker
is a killer and given how many people we
just killed she's not entirely wrong i
like that irrational games took into
consideration how elizabeth would feel
after seeing someone die as it's not
something you can simply brush off this
also extends to the numerous other
things elizabeth does like cover her
ears during the scene when the noise
gets too loud or just interacting with
the environment like when she asks for
cotton candy it's incredibly small but
it heightens the experience of the game
i find myself always looking at
elizabeth waiting to see where she'll go
next or what she'll say since her input
was always interesting to hear this also
extends to her relationship with booker
bioshock 2 had this father-daughter
style dynamic as well with delta and
eleanor but what i really think makes
infinite better in this regard is
because we actually get to spend time
with elizabeth obviously the reason why
we can't see eleanor is due to the plot
but still elizabeth acts like this
little girl who has seen the world for
the first time and booker becomes this
father figure making sure she doesn't
run off and get into danger and i really
love the dynamic they have after some
time booker and elizabeth will come
across lady comstock's airship as they
plan to use that as their means of
escape but it's blocked and can only be
accessed by using the shock jockey vigor
this then leads to duo to cornelius
slate who has a really interesting
section as it forces booker to confront
his past slate and booker knew each
other before the events of the game as
they were at wounded knee together after
this booker would reflect on his life
and his actions while slate would meet
and join father comstock who would then
lead them to the boxer rebellion both of
these events were gruesome and tragic
times for booker so having him relive
his past while also having elizabeth
discover his past was an intense moment
we the player figured this out alongside
elizabeth and after this encounter you
start to view booker as a completely
different person for better or for worse
both wounded knee and the boxer
rebellion were also real world events
that happened which made learning about
these all the more interesting wounded
knee was an awful massacre that saw an
army of united states soldiers kill over
300 native americans during this
massacre booker was accused by a
sergeant that he had native american
blood in him to avoid the backlash and
repercussions that would come from this
booker decided to prove to his fellow
men that he was indeed a true soldier of
america by scalping many native
americans and then burning dozens of
teepees wounded knee is not only an
incredible part of the story as it
defines booker's character but it's more
important for us the player as we get to
see who booker really is and are given
the option to form our own opinion about
him that will continue to stay
throughout the whole game for the
bioshock series this was a nice twist as
we went from having two samaritans who
got caught up in terrible circumstances
to a protagonist who was a mass murderer
it's a unique idea for the series and
one that i welcomed as for the other
tragic event in history the boxer
rebellion was a war that started because
a group of chinese anti-christians
called the boxers were killing and
massacring christian missionaries
churches and parishioners throughout all
of northern china in real life this led
to the creation of the eight nation
alliance which included countries like
the british empire the united states
russia japan and many others all of whom
were against the boxers as for bioshock
infinite it's unclear whether colombia
fought them alone or joined the eight
nation alliance but given why this
rebellion started it's obvious colombia
wanted some revenge even if it didn't
directly involve them these events were
a part of comstock's history which means
it was also part of colombia's history
which is why there's an exhibit of the
events in the hall of heroes however
slate doesn't like the exhibit as it
claims that comstock was not only at the
battle of wounded knee but was the hero
of the boxer rebellion he's technically
wrong but he's technically right but
we'll get to that later after the
exhibit we can make it to the main
attraction which is another exhibit
related to lady comstock here is where
we also get to learn about the vox
populi since entering colombia we have
heard a few rumors about them and this
is no different according to the exhibit
we learned that not only is elizabeth
the daughter of comstock but lady
comstock was also murdered by her
servant daisy fitzroy who would
eventually become the leader of the vox
populi a rebellious organization looking
to put an end to the current rule of
colombia and take it for their own many
of its members are irish and
african-american two groups of people
who are notably discriminated against
within colombia once again this is
another great moment for the story as we
not only got some key information but
elizabeth is now learning her own
backstory alongside us and the
revelation that the man who had locked
her up in the tower was her father is a
terrifying feeling for her the seed of
the prophet shall sit the throne
and drown in flame the mountains of man
you're comstock's daughter no i can't be
i i can't he wants you to follow his
footsteps well i want a puppy but that
doesn't mean i'm gonna get one
the beginning of that speech is also
pretty important as comstock says the
seed of the prophet shall sit the throne
and drown in flame the mountains of man
remember this for later once all the
exhibits are done we can confront slate
so we can get our shock jockey and it's
here where it's probably a good time to
mention this game's combat infinite's
combat bothers me quite a lot bioshock 1
and 2 had the uniqueness of the splicers
who not only had some decent personality
via combat dialogue but also looked
unique and were just overall a blast to
fight against i don't feel the same way
when i play infinite maybe it's because
i like the older game's health system or
that those games had different ammo
types with actual unique weapons or the
beauty of the plasmids but something
always feels off every time i play one
other issue is that theme of morality
there is none of that in this game and
for a series that is stuck with it for
two straight games it's a shame to see
it disappear in this title this may have
something to do with how the narrative
is structured and how we're given the
illusion of choice but bioshock 1 and 2
did the same thing and managed to give
us multiple endings to this story and
also feel like our choices had some
amount of weight to it this also extends
to the larger enemies in the game
whereas in bioshock 1 deciding to fight
the big daddies was an impossible feat
you were supposed to view this as a
difficult battle but assuming you were
skilled enough to prevail you were given
an immense amount of gear and atom to
use infinite doesn't have this as
there's no decisions that hold any
weight you just simply go from objective
to objective fighting people along the
way without a care in the world and
while the game isn't that long it does
get quite boring when you just want to
learn the story but are stuck fighting a
bunch of enemies because elizabeth can't
pick the lock needed to progress even
the original games fell into this trap
sometimes but they still managed to add
something to the combat like sandra
cohen's art exhibit which is really just
a ton of combat back to back but with
the added distinctiveness of the enemies
themselves and the fact that we had to
take pictures of their corpses so that
we can display them it added a bit of
variety it wasn't much variety but at
least made the combat a bit more
engaging the combat in infinite is very
actiony and streamlined you aren't
really fighting for resources or
upgrades as elizabeth more often than
not will keep you stocked when needed
there's no health kits the player can
have in stock and the shield also
regenerates given these additions and
literally just how the combat arenas
work in this game it's clear that
irrational games went for a more action
adventure title rather than one that had
immersive sim or survival elements it's
practically a railroaded shooter without
any variety this lack of variety also
extends to the levels themselves if i'm
being honest infinite may have some of
the worst levels in the series colombia
itself is gorgeous just like rapture but
throughout the game we were able to see
different areas all with different
backstories i can name quite a few of
the levels in the past games but i can
barely remember the names of a couple
locations in colombia and the only ones
i do remember were only because of one
scene in the level that either i hated
or i loved other than the actual beauty
creativity and the lore that the level
brings into the world bioshock 1 had
levels like hephaestus medical pavilion
ford frolic arcadia and so many more
that serve some purpose ford frolic was
the entertainment center run by sander
cohen and arcadia was a botanical garden
that also helps supply rapture's oxygen
infinite levels don't take from what
bioshock once started there is rarely
any levels that actually attempt to show
that colombia is more than just a few
areas made by some developers there's no
levels that showcase how the quantum
particles can suspend the city in the
air how the people of the city can even
breathe this high up considering at the
very least oxygen would not be plentiful
at 15 000 feet or even where the energy
comes from to even power this city
emporia a late-game area which is known
to be a place in colombia for the
ultra-rich looks no different than the
welcoming center in the beginning of the
game thankfully it's not all bad as
shantytown is a really good level that
does highlight a lot of differences
between the others but that's only a
couple levels out of the total of 16.
all these problems make it quite
difficult to play again and yes this is
more of a critique of the gameplay
rather than the story which is the
opposite of the intended purpose for
this video but we have discussed in the
previous games how its gameplay was
intertwined with the narrative thanks to
the themes of morality with the little
sisters and how we're in this unknown
location so by making the game more
survival focused it tied the game's
combat to its story infinite just feels
like a playground adventure where we go
on ziplines and mow down dozens of
enemies without at all considering that
we're literally in the same situation as
delta and jack we are lost in an unknown
city and have to struggle to survive but
infinite fails to convey this early we
talked about the vox populi and it's
after the fight with slade where we get
to learn more about them elizabeth
during our journey says how she wants to
escape and go to paris but as we
remember booker has a job to do and that
means we go to new york so when he takes
control of the first lady's airship he
sets the destination to new york
elizabeth catches on to this and gets a
bit emotional honestly i was going to
mention how awful her crying is but it
does make sense as she is faking it so
that booker drops his guard so she can
knock him out elizabeth disappears right
after this as she was about to depart
but the vox populi show up booker then
meets with daisy and they come to an
agreement if booker gets daisy the guns
needed for the army then she'll give him
the airship back where they drop us off
though is fincton a place owned by
jeremiah fink the one we saw in the
intro even though this is the first time
we are without elizabeth it doesn't last
that long as we'll eventually catch up
to her and while we do repair the
relationship it's not back to what it
was before as elizabeth is a bit more
cynical and only joins him because he's
the only way she'll get to paris she
sees booker as a means to an end similar
to how booker viewed elizabeth in the
beginning we're only halfway through the
game and already the relationship has
taken so many different turns and it's
only going to continue as we progress
and i must say it's really well done as
i said we're now in finton and this is
one of those locations where i only
remember it because of one scene ten ten
now ten nine fifty nine and fifty any
lower now nine and ten nine ten
nine nine eight and thirty three
i don't really have much to add here i
think the scene speaks for itself people
are so desperate enough for jobs that
they're willing to fight others to get
it what they're auctioning here by the
way is their time saying that they can
get the job done faster than anyone else
the first auction that occurred was for
someone to haul a half a ton of coal
from fink manufacturing to shantytown
and the guy who won believed he could do
it in 5 minutes and 50 seconds it's
unclear what happens but i can only
assume if they fail they probably don't
get paid for the job or unable to work
other jobs due to the lack of work ethic
in the eyes of the company besides being
the location of some of the worst
conditions in colombia it's also here
where the story goes off the rails i
briefly talked about the tares and how
they are portals to other dimensions and
all of that is shown here we make it to
the gunsmith location and discover that
he's gone however his wife is still here
and says that they took him and locked
him up we end up finding where he's
located and also find out that he was
being tortured for information but when
we arrive in his cell we discover that
he's dead the lu tessa show up again and
in a cryptic way explain that while we
see mr lin as dead he can also be seen
as alive it's just a matter of
perspective that's when a tear appears
and shows that mr lin was never killed
in another universe meaning we can still
get the guns to daisy of course in this
version of colombia mr lin is alive but
that's not the only thing that's changed
the police we killed earlier are now
alive again but something's wrong
they're alive but they're dead they are
alive but they remember being dead so
they're going insane this sort of
situation happens a few times with
booker where he starts bleeding out of
nowhere the reason he's bleeding is
because his mind is taking his current
memories and combining it with new
memories and it's causing this nauseous
effect in his mind and causing him to
bleed they are alive in this world but
they remember their other selves in a
previous timeline dying thanks to these
new memories suddenly appearing in their
minds when booker enters this new
colombia adding on to more changes we
see that mr lin is alive but is going a
bit insane but more importantly his wife
is white now and now a devout follower
of father comstock as opposed to the
original version who was asian and
praying to buddha we learned from his
wife that the weapons he made are in
shanti town which is our next stop
shanti town is a pretty good level as we
get to see how the lower class of
colombia live there are signs everywhere
asking people for food or for a doctor
and the bar down the street even has a
corpse in it and judging from the knife
and the blood on the table i think we
know why as usual we're gonna need to
push through lots of guards to make it
to our objective but once we arrive we
hit another roadblock while in this
columbia mr lin is alive the tools are
chained up and extremely heavy however
there's another tear showing that these
tools aren't there meaning they're
already back at the shop so we go
through another tear into another
columbia but once again this isn't the
only thing that has changed
bring us the girl and wipe away the debt
as plans go i'd seen worse except this
girl was already gone
monument island's a damn ghost town it
seems like they evacuated her when they
heard i was here
an old friend told me comstock spirited
her off to that fortress of his
as a one-man job this just went from
betting on the river to
drawing dead
so it seems that elizabeth has been
taken from monument island and since
booker couldn't find her it seemed like
he joined the vox as a way to take down
comstock however judging from the
posters it seems like he died and has
now become a martyr for the vox i also
realized that we're 30 minutes into this
video and i haven't even mentioned the
box of phones yet bioshock infinite like
its predecessors has audio logs in the
form of vox-phones but unlike the other
games i think infident really lacks in
this department as well some of the
audio logs are quite nice as they do
provide a decent amount of story like
some of the ones from booker's past or
most of daisy fitzroy's but many of them
just seem to exist without real
substance i think sixty percent of them
is just speeches from lady comstock and
father comstock about some stuff that
really doesn't matter there is a nice
set of logs from a hattie gerst very
reminiscent of mark meltzer that talks
about her husband and how he came down
with an illness but since there wasn't
much that could be done he decided to
become one of the handymen in hopes of
having a chance at life but ultimately
would eventually perish at the hands of
the vox when he went to work for the
founders as i said there's some pretty
decent story within these vlogs i just
feel like the previous games did it a
whole lot better getting back on track
we're still in shantytown in this new
columbia but booker starts bleeding
again since the memories of his current
self and his other self from this
universe are blending together in this
columbia the vox not only have a
foothold in shantytown but also in
finton as there are vox forces
everywhere but every action has its
consequences in this world while the
weapons and tools were brought to the
box mr lin and his wife are dead
elizabeth is upset at this revelation as
while there probably wasn't much they
could have done to prevent this outcome
it's still something she hadn't
considered that across multiple
timelines and universes people can be
dead and alive at any time on a more
positive note though we did get daisy
her gun so we can get the airship back
at least that's what booker believes
because that deal was made with the
first columbia's daisy fitzroy there's
no way to be sure that this daisy made
the same deal i'm not sure if this is to
showcase how confused booker has gotten
after jumping through two different
worlds or a lack of polish when it comes
to this game's writing after joining the
vox and pushing back the founders daisy
calls us and our cover's been blown
daisy believes that we're an impostor of
the real book or dewitt so she has the
vox attack us once we battle through
some of the vox we meet daisy in just at
the perfect time to see her kill fink
and while cool i gotta ask what was with
this blood wiping thing i'm not even
going to talk about the risk of
infection that could happen from this
but what was the point was it to show
that she's somehow crazy or that she's
badass that she'll kill someone and wipe
their blood on her face
i don't know it just felt really
unnecessary once again after more
fighting we can finally confront her but
she has a child held hostage and the
only way to stop her is to have
elizabeth sneak in and kill her just
like the many interactions we've seen
before this makes total sense anyone
would be in a state of disarray after
taking someone's life especially someone
like her who's a very caring person this
decision however changes elizabeth she
becomes a woman now instead of just a
girl this is symbolized in her cutting
her hair and also changing her outfit
and demeanor you may be confused as to
how this is supposed to make her a woman
but the dlc will explain this but we
have the airship and can now escape to
colombia except nothing's ever easy this
highlights a glaring issue with this
game and that's the constant
backtracking and cliffhanging when it
comes to completing objectives the other
two games did this as well but they
weren't as bad as infinite to give you a
refresher we got the objective to reach
the first lady's airship when we landed
on the beach but we were then blocked by
the rail system and needed some shock
jockey so we started backtracking after
getting the shock jockey elizabeth
knocks us out since booker was going to
take her to new york instead so now we
have to join daisy and get the vox their
guns for the war once again more
backtracking that's also not even
getting into the multiple times we have
to go through fington because mr lin is
dead in one world then alive in another
but the tools aren't here but they're in
another so we go back and forth between
the same area at least three different
times and then finally after all these
objectives are completed totaling about
four hours of playtime songbird comes
back and wrecks the airship i can't
decide whether or not i'd actually be
more upset if we just simply lost the
airship again and had to find it a third
time rather than seeing four hours of
work get destroyed in a matter of
seconds but either option would
definitely not be preferable you
literally spend a third of this game
probably more than that doing this one
objective but the game attempts to
disguise it by giving you small tasks
along the way i would argue this is just
as bad as rescuing atlas's family which
took just as long all for that to fail
as well but not only was this faked and
shows the depths that fontaine was going
to go to succeed but there was actual
emotion behind this scene it goes from
an action-packed race as we try to save
the family before they're killed by
splicers to immediately shifting into a
somber more emotional track of music
with this calming aftermath we were too
late and atlas couldn't save his family
and he pours his heart out during this
scene and emotionally resonates with the
player as not only does atlas want to
kill ryan we do as well booker and
elizabeth just move right along
completely ignoring the fact that the
one thing they've spent hours trying to
find is gone no emotion no break in the
action just another scene with the
luteses it's utterly surreal how i was
the only one who was emotionally torn
because of this yet none of the
characters seem to agree this probably
wouldn't be half as bad if this tragedy
wasn't followed up by probably one of
the worst levels in the entire game
emporia is awful and literally because
of one enemy lady comstock admittedly
from a story perspective it's pretty
good as we learned that father comstock
was sterile due to the multiple tests he
had done with the tares meaning
elizabeth isn't related to father
comstock and then we also discovered
that lady comstock never actually liked
elizabeth and saw her as an illegitimate
child to which she would eventually
attempt to blackmail father comstock by
claiming to tell all of colombia that
elizabeth isn't his daughter he would
then take it upon himself to kill her
for saying this but her servant daisy
had walked in during the killing forcing
comstock to pin the blame on her which
of course explains how daisy became the
leader of the vox on top of this we also
learned that the lu tesses were killed
by fink who was ordered by father
comstock to carry out the hit it is some
genuinely incredible backstory and its
story i've been waiting to hear it's
just a shame it's surrounded by this
level i can't be 100 certain on this
claim but i do hope that many can agree
that lady comstock's boss fight is just
bad both narratively and mechanically
the series has always struggled with
boss fights and this is no exception the
whole reason we even fight her is
because elizabeth and booker are once
again hit with another roadblock which
is a door that will only open for lady
comstock and even though she has been
dead for some time she's been locked in
an airtight coffin to preserve her body
but when we open it she becomes a ghost
and raises the dead to fight us this is
truly where the game went off the rails
it felt so far-fetched to me that i was
genuinely confused on how this was even
possible the real reason the ghost is
even an entity to begin with is because
it's a combination of both elizabeth's
feeling towards her and lady comstock's
body that's why she acts angrily towards
us just as elizabeth felt angry at lady
comstock for not being her mother the
two end up forgiving each other though
for the pain they cause one another
which ultimately allows us to get into
comstock's house and lady comstock
herself gets to rest in peace i
understand bioshock is a series where we
have magic and cities that are located
in uninhabitable environments but i
don't recall the series ever going this
far with its science fiction elements
the only other time we saw ghosts in
this game was back in rapture but these
were cleared up by the story in a fairly
believable way which was due to adam not
only altering people's genetic code but
by also constantly being recycled thanks
to the little sisters it caused certain
memories of other people to be shown in
the form of ghostly apparitions was it a
bit much
maybe a little but there was at least a
valiant attempt to try to explain the
phenomenon and also ground it into the
world this game's version of ghosts is
just the complete opposite she's also an
absolute bullet sponge and while i
didn't mind it the first time my mood
got progressively worse after the second
and third time we fight her the same
exact way after finally being led inside
we're stopped once again by resident
roadblock but this time songbird
actually succeeds and manages to take
elizabeth away from us booker manages to
just barely survive but as he attempts
to chase her down he stops momentarily
as he notices that snow is on the ground
despite it being july booker has been
pulled into yet another version of
colombia the screams of elizabeth that
we hear in game are not actually
happening in the current columbia as he
discovers that they're from a terror
this terror is the previous columbia we
are just in implying he's now somewhere
else this columbia is what would happen
if comstock fulfilled this prophecy i
told you earlier to remember that quote
the drowning flames the mountain of man
this is why this world of colombia is
one where comstock passes away and
elizabeth has become his successor at
the end of his prophecy is colombia
fighting against the united states we
see a much older elizabeth as well in
this world and it's discovered that she
brought us here into this world to show
us what could happen if comstock wins
she then gives us a note for elizabeth
but doesn't tell us what it means as for
her eyes only old lady elizabeth then
sends us back into colombia and we're
just in time as we can see that they are
in the process of extracting elizabeth's
power knowing what can happen if they
succeed we put a stop to it and rescue
elizabeth we're now just a few steps
away from reaching comstock all we have
to do is just get aboard his ship and if
you weren't convinced that infinite was
a playground adventure game with cool
explosions and high octane combat then
this surely should have convinced you
booker as a one-man army charges towards
the airship killing dozens of soldiers
along the way he also has to defend the
airship by himself with the occasional
help of songbird as an ending battle
it's heroic tough and really cool as an
ending for bioshock it's absurd i've
already explained in detail my issues
about this game's new combat style as it
doesn't fit with the themes of bioshock
and this fight was a big reason why
seeing as we finally made it to the
ending we can now understand the story
except we aren't there just yet bioshock
infinite really likes to hold the plot
twist until the very last minute in the
airship is the prophet himself comstock
doesn't tell us anything and instead
wants dewitt to tell elizabeth the real
truth even though he has no idea what's
going on due to his ignorance he takes
this opportunity to drown comstock and
put an end to his reign honestly i've
been waiting for booker to be completely
honest about his feelings towards
elizabeth and i'm so glad he was finally
able to do that it's clear that he cares
about her he may not have been before
when he first met her but over time this
became more than just a job for him
further solidifying that the way the
relationship was written over the course
of the game was stellar and by far one
of the best parts of this game fast
forwarding a bit we defend the airship
and are able to use songbird to destroy
the tower which houses the siphons that
took elizabeth's powers once those were
destroyed she regains all of them back
immediately after this we take songbird
down to rapture which kills him due to
the water pressure we then take a
bathysphere to a weird world with dozens
of lighthouses these doors are like
physical doors to other worlds and with
all her powers back she can see into all
of them regardless if that door is in
the past present or future she cannot
only see the doors but also what's
inside of them she's practically
all-knowing at this point which explains
why the ending of the game happens the
way that it does at the very end booker
is taken back to the baptism he had
before the events of the game but he
refuses just like before however booker
is told by elizabeth that he didn't
refuse in some worlds and that altered
things in that world it's also revealed
that because of this event booker is
also father comstock after the events of
wounded knee booker was regretful of his
actions and saw clarity through religion
but that was in his world in some worlds
he also refused but in others he agreed
to the baptism those who agreed would
become father comstock if booker refused
he stays the depressed and regretful
booker dewitt but if he agreed he's
reborn a new man one who was cleared of
all sins and is reborn again in the face
of god this leads him down a new holier
path and a new man needs a new name so
he would then change it to zachary hale
comstock that is the true plot twist of
bioshock infinite booker has been
fighting himself the whole game but
we're still not done yet once again this
game is about constants and variables
everything in booker's life was a
constant up until the baptism every
single version of booker whether they
stayed booker or became comstock all
took a part in wounded knee that's why
slate was mad at comstock for claiming
to be a wounded knee when he knew he
wasn't there he was but not as comstock
as this was before the baptism once
booker goes to the baptism the world
splits if booker rejects he then stays
the booker dewitt during this time
booker would then join the pinkerton
detective agency where he would garner a
reputation for ending worker strikes
with severe violence it was also here
where he would meet annabelle the woman
who would eventually become his wife
they would then end up having a child
anna yes i know how confusing that
sounds but this birth would end up
causing more problems for booker not
only did annabelle die during the
pregnancy but due to her death he
acquired a massive gambling and drinking
problem leaving him in massive debt
however robert lutes arrived at his
office one day and offered to take anna
from him which would absolve his debt
that phrase bring us the girl and wipe
away the debt was not about rescuing
elizabeth it was about selling anna to
roberts that he could be debt free right
after this happened though booker
regretted his actions and chased robert
down an alley where he also meets
comstock and rosalind just as he's about
to pull her through her pinky is caught
and taken off anna is gone and it's due
to this decision that booker decided to
get the ad on his hand for his daughter
anna dewitt but while he may know her as
anna we know her by a different name
because we know someone else whose pinky
is gone elizabeth
she is booker's daughter let me dial
things back a bit and talk about
comstock because then this will tie
things together should booker accept the
baptism he would then become comstock he
would then eventually meet rosalind and
create colombia during this time as
leader and as prophet he gained a very
large following of devotees one of whom
was called annabelle the alternate
version of annabelle dewitt but now
annabelle comstock or as we know her
lady comstock but we know the pair
couldn't have a kid due to comstock
being sterile thanks to those tare tests
so he sought out an heir and the three
of them comstock rosalind and robert
determined that an heir from another
world could work this is what caused
robert to meet with booker take anna
then jump back into their world the only
question is what is what the lutes is
trying to help us and encourage booker
to find elizabeth well the pair ended up
discovering what we did that the
destruction of new york would happen if
things went to plan so they attempted to
fix their mistake but as we talked about
earlier they were killed before they
could try however for some reason they
were able to move across space and time
whenever and wherever they wanted
allowing them both to exist and not
exist remember it's all a matter of
perspective seeing as they were still
technically alive they continued with
their plan and found booker they then
took booger from his world into one
where comstock was in hopes of redoing
their mistake but it didn't work if the
coin flip is to be taken literally then
this isn't the first time they've tried
to get booker to kill comstock and if
i'm not mistaken then we are the 123rd
attempt at this experiment this would
explain why rosalind in the intro is
very annoyed at the experiments as they
keep failing elizabeth had learned all
of this and both booker and her agreed
that the only way to prevent comstock
from ever doing all of this was to
smother him in his crib when he was a
baby booker meant this literally
elizabeth meant this metaphorically
technically comstock's first day on
earth was after the baptism so by
killing booker before the baptism takes
place she would end up killing comstock
before he was even born the only reason
this works is because the baptism is the
constant the outcome is the variable but
by killing him before the baptism we
change the constant and thus change the
entire timeline since booker was never
given a choice at the baptism the
variables couldn't exist thus removing
all the comstocks and columbias from the
timeline it's a bit confusing but i've
always understood this ending as all the
bookers that would accept the baptism
meaning they would become comstock would
all die and those who don't accept the
baptism don't die since they never
become comstock you may notice during
the scene that none of them are wearing
the necklace we gave her meaning that
our elizabeth is still alive basically
our elizabeth the one we've been with
since the beginning of the game is kind
of like the luteses whereas the lutesis
receive their trans-dimensional powers
after death elizabeth seemed to just
have them because she can open and
create tears after this bombshell of
information we get an after credits
cutscene that shows booker waking up to
anna crying it's unclear how to
interpret this but some have claimed
that this is simply just another booker
before he sold anna or that because the
timelines got reset so to speak that
everything is back to normal but then
there's been even more discussion about
whether or not anna is even truly in the
crib because we never see her personally
i think they just added this because
they wanted the game to have a
mysterious cliffhanger as it's really
hard to care about when there isn't any
substance to go off of but it's not a
huge problem since the answer doesn't
matter anyway this though is the full
and transparent story of bioshock
infinite what an absolute wild story
this has become so firstly i didn't mind
the homage they paid to rapture although
it does feel a bit like nostalgia bait
more than anything to remind us that
we're still playing a bioshock game it
was cool but it felt a little forced
however the ending overall was fantastic
admittedly it's very confusing and
definitely something i didn't understand
but as time went on things started to
click more and more there is a growing
debate though amongst the community
about this ending it's probably the only
bioshock game that is as heavily split
some saying that this is the best in the
series and claiming that if you don't
like it it's because you don't
understand it but some argue back and
say they do understand it and still
dislike it or that this complexity is
reason enough for them to dislike it as
for me though i think this ending is
really good what i've preferred infinite
nako as far as it did with its sci-fi
elements absolutely i think the
introduction of tares multiple universes
and quantum mechanics was a bit
unnecessary as this made the story a bit
of a chore to sift through so i could
finally understand the meaning behind
everything but despite that infinite
story wraps up quite nicely and as a
whole it's pretty great once again
infinite manages to completely fool the
player despite the expected plot twist
and the relationship between booker and
elizabeth was easily the best part of
the game it also seemed to do exactly
what it set out to do provide the fans a
bioshock game that doesn't have many
callbacks to the other games allowing it
to live on its own that's what i would
have said if they didn't release the dlc
bioshock infinite would eventually add a
two-part episodic dlc called burial at c
and when i heard that the dlc was
heading back to our favorite underwater
city i was all years barry let's see
starts with elizabeth entering a
detective's office this detective is
booker dewitt it's a different booker
but the same elizabeth we can piece this
together from multiple conversations
between the two the reason elizabeth
shows up here is because she's hiring
this booker to find a missing girl named
sally considering how strong elizabeth
is thanks to her powers and how much
knowledge she has from those powers we
can assume that there's an underlying
meaning to all of this after accepting
the job booker leaves the office and
we're finally able to see rapture in its
prime and it's magnificent i spent a
good hour in this area just taking
everything in even if it was something
that was pretty much insignificant it
was still great to explore we also get
to see the little sisters up close and
this brings up something we should
mention the time and date for this dlc
is december 31 1958 the same day that
rapture would be under siege by fontaine
and his splicer army this obviously
caused a lot of tension within me while
playing as i knew at some point things
were about to go off furthermore that
means that the little sisters at this
point were only bonded with one big
daddy because this is the same date that
delta and eleanor were patrolling the
hallways of rapture so elizabeth takes
us to sander cohen as she believes that
cohen knows where sally went once again
i really like seeing sandra cohen again
and it also further confirms that he was
always a crazed lunatic even before the
riots on new year's eve to get any
information out of him we need to dance
for him just like his previous subjects
however just like that previous couple
we upset him and fitzpatrick shocks us
by the way if that name rings a bell
here's a quick refresher
oh god you sick [ __ ] let me out of
there
afterwards booker and elizabeth wake up
in a bathysphere that is headed towards
the fontaine department store however we
only get to explore the warehouse
section of it this department store was
sunk by andrew ryan during his fuse with
fontaine he would eventually lock up any
other insane splicers down here so that
rapture could run smoothly this seems to
operate like persephone which was also a
prison in rapture so i guess this means
persephone was for regular inmates and
people ryan believed were going to ruin
his city while the department stores
seem to only be related to fontaine and
his army it's a little weird but i'll go
with it after tons of combat and
exploration we get some backstory on
sally and discover that after fontaine
and the orphanage went down lots of the
little girls were roaming the city sally
came by and booker being nice opted to
give her a place to settle down but he
assumed it would only be temporary she
enjoyed being a runbooker quite a lot
and ended up staying permanently however
this booker like the others was also a
gambler and an alcoholic one day he was
gambling and without noticing sally was
taken booker was then told shortly after
that she was confirmed dead but as we'll
discover soon that was a lie booker and
elizabeth come across sally meaning
she's still in fact alive but she's also
inside of one of the little sister vents
and won't come out elizabeth has the
insane idea to heat up the vents and
lock all the entrances so that she only
has one way to come out after doing this
booker runs to the event to discover
that she has become a little sister
clearly she is scared and agitated so
that alerts her big daddy and were
forced to fight it also i think this is
a plot hole this should be an alpha
series big daddy not the bouncer type we
see here the bouncer and rosie big
daddies of bioshock 1 existed at this
point in time but were only used for
maintenance and underwater excavation
the alpha series were the only ones with
a bond and that bond was with one little
sister after killing the big daddy
though we uncovered the full truth of
episode 1. this booker is actually a
comstock this comstock however is unique
to all the others as instead of
successfully taking anna from booker he
failed not only did booker have more
control of anna but their struggle left
anna's head on khan stock's side
decapitating her overcome with guilt
comstock asked the lutesis to send him
to a place so that he may forget all he
has done this is what caused him to go
to rapture and re-adopt his booker name
comstock is rightfully shocked by this
discovery and tries to apologize but
elizabeth isn't here for apologies and
has him killed by a big daddy episode 1
minus the slight mix-up with the big
daddies was great and once again makes
sense elizabeth at the end of the game
wanted revenge for what comstock did to
her we can see that when booker attempts
to stop her booker of course clarifies
that he wants to kill him for her but
this leaves a hole within her she won't
be allowed to take her anger out on the
man who not only imprisoned her but all
the other elizabeth that are connected
to her she feels all their pain which
makes her want for revenge even greater
plus she also had to drown her own
father so not only could she not enact a
revenge she had to lose booker despite
getting what she wanted which was to
eliminate comstock nothing felt complete
so when she discovered this comstock she
decided to torture him until she was
satisfied obviously this sort of ruins
the ending of the main game since this
was supposed to eliminate all the
comstocks but i think the reason this
occurred was because since comstock left
the columbia reality and entered the
rapture reality he was out of bounds of
the purge as i said though really great
episode but now things are going to
start to dip episode 2 starts with
elizabeth in paris or at least her
version of paris we can tell because of
how dramatic everything is all the
residents greet her and treat her like
royalty at times everyone's also singing
along together and there's even a bird
that sings as well when it lands on her
finger everything is absolutely
exaggerated but it's all taken away when
sally arrives elizabeth wakes up and not
only is there a ghost version of booker
here but atlas shows up atlas decides to
shoot elizabeth but is stopped when she
tells him that she can get him back to
rapture with the help of dr su chong
atlas is also now using sally as a
bargaining chip to get elizabeth to do
his bidding i'm starting to get
flashbacks one thing i sort of glossed
over was booker as a ghost what seems to
be a figment of her imagination
something she made up she clearly cares
about booker that is her father after
all so she's probably still trying to
deal with the guilt of killing him back
in the main game but we aren't done with
the bizarre twists as we find
elizabeth's dead body furthermore due to
this she isn't able to see the different
realities and the tears in the doors
like she used to she's just a normal
human girl without any way to leave
rapture when she's done the lutes has
warned that if she went to rapture to
enact revenge on this comstock she would
collapse so to speak i think collapse in
this context is the other elizabeth's
merging with her removing her powers and
becoming a normal human again i don't
think it's explained why she loses her
powers but it's possible that entering
the different reality changed her powers
a bit but that's just speculation more
importantly though i have to ask how did
she die this is confirmed to be the same
elizabeth from the main game the same
one who trapped songbird and rapture
immediately after getting her powers
back but she was somehow stopped by a
big daddy it's possible that she isn't
on the same power level anymore due to
her being in a different reality as we
can see her struggling to open a very
tiny tear early in the episode so maybe
what i say is true or maybe i'm just
making creative excuses for the devs to
get away with this either way
elizabeth's new objective is to rescue
sally she feels guilt over using her as
bait and hurting her to torture comstock
she realizes that just as comstock used
her to get what he wants she used sally
to get what she wanted making her know
better than the man she despised she
wants to make things right and make sure
sally has a future and to do this she
needs to work with atlas and this is
where i started to lose interest infant
tried so hard to separate itself from
the other game and it succeeded whether
or not you agree with this decision is
up to you but you can't deny that it's
its own experience so why are we going
back and using story from the first game
it seems like the studio just couldn't
get away from their pride and joy that
his bioshock won and needed to come up
with a story to sell the dlc firstly
elizabeth needs to find sue chong and
while she doesn't find him she does find
his temporary lab in here is photos of
colombia as well as a terror it's
explained that the terror elizabeth used
to get to rapture took her here so soo
chong with the assistance of andrew ryan
moved his equipment here to study the
terror eventually he would come in
contact with jeremiah fink and the two
would collaborate and steal each other's
ideas this led to the creation of the
vigors and songbird it also led to the
creation of the big daddies but only
partially as soo chong was still trying
to figure out how a songbird bonded with
elizabeth as this was the critical piece
he was missing when it came to the big
daddies with this discovery elizabeth
realizes that she can use the tear to
get into colombia and grab the lutest
particle so that she can make the
department store flow just like columbia
floats sadly though the device was
destroyed so she needs to repair it once
it's fixed we can take the tear to
colombia you may be confused as to how a
colombia like this exists and honestly
so am i it seems like the main game
really tied things up so by adding a new
colombia it sort of invalidates all that
progress even if this is just a terror
to the past it's still a colombia this
shouldn't really be here furthermore we
also see a behind-the-scenes
conversation between the lutesis and
daisy we learned that the lutesis were
behind the actions of daisy back in
fington explaining that daisy will die
and that she needs to play her part in
order for elizabeth to become a woman
and once again i'm left confused daisy
has spent years under the oppression of
colombia and its residents she's also
been a leader of the vox for presumably
a few years as well and she's willing to
throw all this away because the lutesis
tell her what to do but i remind you
that the lutes has worked for father
comstock the person she's trying to kill
so how can she even trust them
furthermore if the lutes has even
managed to convince her by showing her
other realities or by predicting the
future then this ruins part of the main
game's story as booker could have easily
just told her that he was from a
different timeline and not an imposter
which could have stopped all the people
we killed that were a part of the vox
it's never explained what ultimately
convinced her so the team is once again
able to get away with this vague scene
changing the story by giving away very
little information that a was never
hinted at and b should have never even
happened is not good storytelling and
also in an effort to clown this scene
again because i think it's funny all
they said was to take the boy hostage
nothing about the blood wiping so once
again i have to ask what the point was
eventually elizabeth will grab the blue
test particle but tsujong won't let her
leave until she gets him hair of the
test subject that was bonded to songbird
which is quite funny as he is literally
talking to that test subject the hair
sample is located in fink's office and
is a really nice location as we get to
see all the tests that he ran trying to
get songbird to connect with elizabeth
it's also pretty horrifying the depths
he was willing to go to to do something
like this like hooking up an animal to a
mask that would constantly pump oxytocin
into their lungs as well as the other
failed test subjects still in the
laboratory elizabeth then grabs the hair
sample and delivers it to su chong by a
pneumo tube and i don't think it's ever
explained in this game but shouldn't the
numo tubes be connected i can't imagine
that the two packages the item and
floats it across the water so how does
this get from point a to point b when
fontaine died ryan forced suchong to
work for him and that's why his new lab
was at the artemis suites far away from
this department store plus the store is
thousands of meters below rapture since
ryan sunken so is the pneumotube still
connected to the other tube or was there
never a tube in the first place it's not
a huge concern just something i noticed
after delivering the hair ryan appears
on the intercom and attempts to kill us
we escape his thugs make it to the
desired location use the loot test
particle to float the department store
back up to rapture and then get knocked
out by atlas's men after this the story
goes back to the roots of bioshock 1 as
atlus wants us to look for the ace in
the hole who of course is jack and while
i was very excited to see jack in some
fashion i don't even really think this
was necessary in the over 10 years since
i played the first bioshock game not
once did i wonder how atlas got jack i
think it's more important that he got
jacket all more than how he got him
there's also a myriad of ways you could
have explained that he got him to
rapture this is going to be a bit bold
of me but i'd like to rewrite this
episode in a way that would make more
sense at least to me firstly remove any
mention of atlas up until this point
allow elizabeth to get up and question
how she is alive along with booker it'll
draw more attention to how elizabeth
ended episode 1 standing and is now
starting this episode on the ground
maybe even add some blood as well to
show that she didn't pass out but was
actually injured with atlas in the
picture all i could care about was him i
didn't even bother questioning how
booker even got here the way booker's
written into this episode is totally
fine i'm actually okay with him just
being a figment of her imagination the
rest of the episode should be spent
trying to find sally and then this would
be a good time to have sally also be
held by sue chong since it'll force
elizabeth to go to colombia and get her
hair in exchange for sally this however
though does involve the lootest particle
in colombia something i'd prefer to
avoid in this episode so maybe we can
have some joke scene where elizabeth
reveals to sue chong that she is in fact
the test subject and then maybe have soo
chong freak out and get a little angry
at the fact the solution to his issue
was literally right in front of him and
seeing as he's in rapture and not the
department store this could make sun be
the sole reason the sword was lifted as
he needs her hair this not only connects
the following scene with andrew ryan
where he says that the deal between su
chong and elizabeth was not one he was
authorized to make but this also fits
narratively with sue chong as a
character who not only worked with
fontaine before he died and could maybe
discover the real identity of atlas but
also show that he is still a person
willing to do anything to get what he
wants once elizabeth makes it to sue
chong she can then drop off her hair and
then right when she meets sally she gets
knocked out by some thugs which leads to
the scene right here once this starts
have the bag stay on elizabeth's head
but have atlas talk to his crew while
we're here it sets up atlas but also
lets the veteran players get excited as
his accent is very recognizable they
could even change the name to man
instead of atlas and the subtitles
momentarily so that the reveal isn't
spoiled then when the hype of his
appearance is still high rip the bag off
and show him even keeping this part
where the light blocks his face but then
reveals him as he steps closer would
have also worked as well personally i
would have preferred this dlc just
continue its own story and have atlas be
revealed in the last few moments since
atlas is now a main character in this
episode from the start it takes all
focus off everyone else as he's easily
the most important character in this
episode doing this would also remove the
questionable decisions that elizabeth
makes throughout this dlc as from the
moment she meets with him she knows that
she'll betray him and it ruins all the
build up when it's not only hammered in
multiple times that atlas will likely
betray her but also the fact that
elizabeth keeps helping him despite
knowing she won't get the upper hand on
him as we discover at the end the reason
she's doing this is because within all
the doors there was a timeline that
shows sally having a future thanks to
jack rescuing her but to do this she
needs to go along with the events of the
story in order to make this all happen
which not only undermines all the power
and skill atlas has as a leader but also
makes the reveal of how atlas got his
hands on jack just really awkward
furthermore the only reason she was able
to do any of this was because of booker
who reminds her that she used to see all
the doors meaning she has all the
memories of all the doors regardless of
whether it was the past present or
future so booker tries to get her to
remember where the location of the ace
and the hole is this confirmed a
suspicion i had and that was that booker
was placed in this episode strictly to
explain plots and discoveries the
writers couldn't explain on their own
and this makes everything feel so forced
just have booker's stay a memory her
memory of booker the booker who she grew
to love and appreciate and have him be
the shoulder she can cry on they are
father and daughter after all don't add
this current booker that is helping
discover the next step in the story
because elizabeth can't remember or is
incapable of making a decision it just
feels like such a waste to have the
story the way it is now and it goes back
to what i said earlier as it answers a
question we didn't even really need
answered the best thing to come from
this part though was the interrogation
scene which makes me extremely
uncomfortable where's me ace in the hole
i don't
know
what else rests in the lobe
creativity
individuality
personality
in short
what makes you
huge continuing with the story though
elizabeth needs to get to su chong's
clinic in order to find info on jack she
then finds the paper that has the would
you kindly pass phrase and then gives it
to atlas during this level we do get to
see how soochong died rather than
hearing it and while cool the story is
doing their thing again where it's
trying to fit elizabeth into the plot by
having her be the sole reason behind all
these events she was the reason that the
big daddies could bond to any little
sister she was then responsible for su
chong's death and is of course
responsible for the events of the whole
series since she gave atlas the
passphrase for jack it's completely
unnecessary to do all of this and i have
no idea why they thought this was a good
idea also unless i'm mistaken i'm pretty
sure the bonding process was created
using pheromones of the big daddies
combined with the mental conditioning
that the little sisters underwent we use
the pheromones ourselves in bioshock 1
and we get to see the little sisters
minds in bioshock too so this whole
scene is confusing as it implies that
just a little bit of adam was all that
was needed even though it's known that
the big daddies were spliced beyond
belief to even get them to function in
the suit so they already have atom in
them plus the atom the little sisters
have is probably recycled you could
claim that the little sisters have
unique atoms since their bodies do
contain the sea slug that produces it
but we can see them drinking adam on
occasion in game thus it's recycled
anyway so this is just confusing for no
reason elizabeth has such a vital role
in her own reality but they needed to
make her have the same role in the
rapture reality but it was just
unnecessary now instead of saying that
the addiction of adam the feud between
fontaine and ryan and the values of
rapture were all contributing factors to
not only the downfall of rapture but the
events of the game it can now just be
boiled down to elizabeth did it to help
sally it ruins years of work and that is
extremely upsetting after elizabeth gets
the passphrase she gives it to atlas as
she has to sensibly to sally being
rescued to which she receives a wrench
to the head for her assistance we then
get a slideshow of the events that took
place in bioshock 1 and see that her
vision became a reality as sally is
rescued by jack and given a future as
she comes back to reality we can see her
holding sally while elizabeth eventually
succumbs to her wounds and dies thus
ending the dlc burial at sea wasn't
terrible but it definitely wasn't great
either it's a dlc that probably didn't
need to exist but i would have accepted
its existence if it didn't fumble so
hard in the second episode the dlc not
only has a few retcons and plot holes
but also undermines all the story and
world building the original game set out
to create by pinning all the events on
one character a character that shouldn't
have even had this vital of a role in
the first place and arguably shouldn't
have even been here anyway infinite was
made to be different and a separation
from the series and while i didn't
appreciate it that much as i've said
before i will at least commend them for
sticking to their original vision and
trying to create something new despite
that they still couldn't get away from
rapture and thus needed to go back was
it great to see rapture in its prime as
well as the original cast of characters
absolutely but the rest of the dlc
soured any enjoyment that i had from it
bioshock infinite as a whole is a
surreal experience it's got a compelling
story with a wonderful twist and a great
dynamic between the two main characters
and even a decent setup to a dlc in
episode 1 culminating in a good game but
it also has a lack of interesting audio
logs bland gameplay repetitive locations
and an abysmal second episode that ruins
the grey parts infinite established
tearing it down in the process head
infinite just ended at the main game i
would have called it great or even
fantastic but burial at sea went too far
it's said that the series had ended on
such a conflicting note like this where
people are more than likely to argue
whether or not the game was even good to
begin with rather than just appreciating
how far the series has come infinite
leaves a permanent stain on the series
fantastic legacy and that's truly what
upsets me the most
but with that finish we've come to the
end of the video as well as the end of
the bioshock series thank you all for
watching and if you watched the previous
videos thank you for coming along for
the ride the series is definitely one of
the best of all time and i don't think
anyone can dispute that and i'm truly
thankful that i was able to play these
games again so i can share my thoughts
with you even if some of them were quite
negative so thank you for that like the
video if you enjoy and subscribe if
you're new and as always thank you to my
returning viewers for coming back to
another video take care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
bye